and your time starts now what is the
square root of 196 14 wrong 14 correct
how many hearts does an octopus have
three Ron three correct what spice is
derived from crocus sativus saffron feel
like an answer hug uh saffron correct
carbon dioxide very good Wellington New
Zealand correct Saturn our American
cousin the equal sign Harry Potter The
Hobbit
correct miss you Ron please list for us
the god of Mount Olympus Aphrodite
Apollo Aries emis Athena deer diones
aestus hey why haven't you gone on that
show are you scared that you would win
so much money that people would try and
kill you for it you know that's the
thing with lottery winners no it's not
are you scared that your hatred for that
wrong guy is actually a sexual
attraction that you wouldn't know how to
navigate in
person no it just I'm
not good at being looked at that you
[Music]
know